first time really in this whole match  yesterday and today magnus was quite  long on time in a wild position it's  that key word wild wild favors duda  if it's a control position just  maneuvering slow steady that favors  magnus  so okay here we go dude is king just  making its move over to this left side  to stop white's pawn and as ivanka  mentions black's knight eventually is  going to go back the other way  towards the right side of the board and  pick off the remaining white pawns there  once dude has dealt with this left side  of the board that one remaining hope and  uh okay well he doesn't even do that uh  he just steps forward with the black  king  and uh oh wow actually magnus doesn't  even try to save this game he resigns in  a hopeless end game yeah and a big  reaction from the world